bonsoir nous sommes sur andrézieux
machine for pig ces partis nouvelle
partie on commence direct ses parts une
belle partie ça s'était très forte et
très neuf à bas voilà un bas je vous
résume la thématique convient de voir
finalement il ya eu des espèces des
clercs karine kadi papa on a vu un
espèce de cochons sur son trône de fer
on s'est réveillé puis rendormi on avait
une porte qui s'est claqué puis réveillé
voilà alors c'est parti on est parti on
est hyper qu'on commence dans ce nouvel
amnesia où j'ai pris soin j'espère que
ça va pas commencer trop brutalement
papapapa trouve nous j'arrive mon enfant
où es tu faisais part ou je ne sais pas
par là je me sens bien
papapapa par ici o'shea de mega au alors
eu absolument rien apprendre à part un
petit verre de vin poser et on peuvent
apprendre là on pouvait prendre un truc
me prenez pas pour un con voilà il faut
toujours ça remet toujours
ok le coup classique de la poste ferme
la porte fermée mais c'est parce que je
me dis c'est un [ __ ] vis à vis à vis
un truc sur le plafond bomb a écouté on
y va c'est un méchant arrive
oh [ __ ] non j'ai fait j'ai mal fait
peur elle est revenue ici les garçons
bon papa que je suis je fais semblant à
mes fils que leurs blagues sont
rigolotes
en réalité je suis pas sûr officier
dessus boli va alléger ma croupit
bouhout jours c'est pour remplacer la
laine duff a put un homme et venez ici
bon de petits salés gauche du [ __ ] tête de
cochon
parce que le jeu s'appelle une machine
for pig mais oui mais c'est évident
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas faire ce
type du parcours fait non on croit put
ingérable son ken pas à ça le mec
derrière moi mais qui m'observent un
gros pervers mode ajout prôné allez les
enfants ça suffit
où êtes-vous sérénité la plus totale
sérénité la plus totale
vous n'avez pas eu peur moi non plus ok
ça ça m'a calmé je vous cache pas je
faisais le malin j'étais là en la vidéo
aurait eu un mur et sa vaste plaque est
là aussi
non on n'y a pas de porte d'accord bon
on va arrêter de fouiller les champs ça
ne sert à rien on s'en bat les couilles
machiste et c'est de retrouver ses
enfants
j'arrive à même puisqu'à ces bruits
stressant et qui veulent dire qu un
espèce de chose étrange pas loin et
[ __ ] mais on est donc quoi lasser même
pas un manoir là c'est une ville le truc
bonjour alors que fais-tu un homme
écrasé vague et un joli paysage
allez on s'en va à tous ensemble plus
que moi ah bah oui mais je t'avais
oublier excuse moi en soit pas jaloux
comme ça alors abaissé par l'agglo on
peut voir la gaule on va passer par la
droite
ah oui si on prenait les carabines mec
ok on peut pas ça sert même à saissac
carrément rien d'essayer on peut pas sûr
et certain alors bonjour c'est par où je
rejoins complètement
c'est je suis en mode gauche c'est bien
ça qui sonne oui allô précieux fruit de
cactus aide nous cherchons une maman ma
cage ya sûrement des choses là-dedans
absolument pas des gages aux fermes de
toit au laissez moi on allait à une note
mais n'accuse sont des voisins on
s'emballe sec se demande quel joueur
d'amnesia n'a pas juste fermer la note
en orient absolument rien à faire bon ça
me suffit de fouiller
voilà voilà voilà au pied on aura plus
de l'huile et on meurt c'est ça qui
compte
mais c'est peut-être parler en fait
finalement et bien non pas roux et la
sortie au wat
ah j'ai complètement cru entendre la
porte mais je rêve pas là on se cache
sous le bureau de mes cheveux qui
dépasse je te vois tes cheveux n'est pas
du bureau de l'osce à on active et une
vilaine porte secrète
1 les chevaux ils étaient trompeurs
saloperie de chevaux watts revenait chez
les enfants oui c'est dans un manoir
mois à cet âge-là la gt r je serai à
leur place je me vois là je me juste
compris la gorge enfin mourir alors
est-ce que je peux avoir des petits
enfants flippant pour passer devant nous
la pompe pourquoi on à watts
c'est plutôt glauque cette maison bordel
de cochon toujours cette époque
naissance exacte âge de raison
oui cet empire enrichi prix à se faire
saigner à quoi il sert celui d'avoir un
truc là-bas ah bah oui il ouvert la
porte à ils étaient juste là mes enfants
eh bien non
peut-être vers là-bas ou
je comprends pas là c'est quoi le sens
là de cette histoire on est dans une
maison qu'il te rend bien nos enfants
qui s'amusent à nous trop laid et papa
tu cherchais ils savent pas que le père
et plus froussard que mènent bon on
notera la présence de deux petites têtes
d'enfants de fenêtres duo une nouvelle
pièce alors pour courir maintenant comme
je sais comment couilles je joue a mis
en avant à une note et je déconne on
lira jamais le note je m'en fiche
tant qu'à pas d'énigme alors je pense
qu'il faut descendre un peu mais partant
de toutes les portes sont fermées de
façon pas ici papa viens voir
j'arrive je repars votre voix la voix
alors une note est ajouté au journal
j'ai appris que simplement maintenant
d'accord à l'eau claire et des tableaux
une petite fille qui pleure le chat qui
ne pleure pas mais la poupée qui pleure
j à ils doivent être par là peut-être
parler de maître par là
e
7à attendait téléphone hier bien les
gars qu'est ce tu veux non je ne te
connais pas qui êtes vous où sont mes
enfants ils sont pris au piège tendu
sous nos pieds très loin d'ici la
machine et souliers percée inondées il
n'a plus de cloisons les enfants sont
enfermés ils vont m'aider je vous
aiderai délibéré pour vous rétablissez
le courant bondit évacuer l'eau et va
démarrer les grands moteurs
je dois être ça la machine à cochons
hello hello hello
bref pour moi ça je téléphone de merde
la [ __ ] le smartphone de l'époque
sacré smartphones avec une paire de
seins bon alors c'est pas ici on y va
bonjour au mont apic mgr jean qui est un
mec là bas moi je me casse j'ai peur au
revoir je vais m'asseoir sur ce canapé
juste là et attendre bien sagement à mes
enfants à les caméras de merde allez
venez alors on va ouvrir up
alors viens d'entendre quelqu'un se
faire broyer toujours ferme les portes
toujours ok bon on vient juste en temps
quelqu'un se faire broyer quoi oh [ __ ]
et si on lisait les notes comment on ou
l'inventaire à documents découverts
alors devant le journal des russes papa
de tout comme les accusés du monde joue
à cache cache avec ou quand il veut
guerre gronde et alors qu'on accélère
mais ce grand show kuljic les accueils
physiques en tout cas on n'aime pas cet
endroit d'accord donc les mecs qui
n'aime pas cet endroit mais ils jouent à
cache cache pas il pourrait juste se
poser là et faire du piano op hectares
d'arbres et les mecs aiment pas des
trucs pour s'asseoir au prix de 16 à je
suis chaud fob à bonjour
ouh là là c'était déjà très hot l époque
finalement peut-être par la non au hajj
un tender en hippopotamus mon copain et
si [ __ ] on peut pas me te monte dessus
ça serait génial d'avoir une monture aux
abois tepa et pas dans le même état que
tes copains oh là là là qu'on voit les
choses que d'autres ici ou plutôt chez
en quelques bons alors j'ai eu des notes
apparemment fléchi
euh non marocaine ah non mon journal au
journal mon journal à des ours à la
baignoire
moi ça me saoule salle tolèrent ces
trucs là allez on ne peut pas pouvoir là
une porte parfait voilà watts
[ __ ] mais mes enfants ils sont chauves
quoi déjà stage là et [ __ ] elle a
évidemment voilà savait que voilà donc
ça c'est génial j'adore je m'assois sur
ce bon j'ai déjà fait toutefois cette
belle c'est vrai bonjour vous auriez pas
du sucre pour ma tarte aux pommes
non par contre vous avez des animaux
empaillés d'accord pardon s'est moqué au
[ __ ] c'est le château quoi à au beau
fixe
j'en ai marre mais le labyrinthe quoi
juste le labyrinthe dans lequel on est
c'est un truc de malade et j'ouvre une
porte je ressors de mètres après que ne
peut pas se défendre avec un club de
golf
donc on devra dommage donc là il ya deux
couloirs hommes et au wat
pourquoi pourquoi ils font des choses
compliquées sont classés dont on est
arrivés ok donc logiquement peut-être
par là à une porte ouverte une porte
fermée valu à alain madelin il est tombé
à l'eau ah mais ça c'est là on était
derrière des gens d'air qui nous voilà
j'en suis sûr une salle de bains faut
faut rétablir l'eau il ya pas moyen de
rétablir l'eau ici non seulement pas
toujours pas à fame se bouger non elle
mais tout est fermé quoi mais quel genre
de personne ferme tout sa maison
doit rétablir l'eau le courant et j'ai
pas trop quoi bon y'a rien ici je me
casse
et puis tu ne clés cachées en fait à un
visiteur au design et maloney fait
jamais refusé non seulement récupérer
pour y abriter un bon d'accord très bon
star lundi et ce quand même quoi [ __ ]
amer mais y'a pas un truc à rétablir
l'eau là comme ça on va d'un joli pas si
je suis le baratin non tu veux regarder
une chaise et sont partout
ah ah ah
what d'accord voilà donc quand je vous
dis qu'il ya des gens qui observent les
autres dans leur bain je ne vous mens
même pas mais ben [ __ ] de scream arrêt
je sens si j'ai un truc comme ça qui est
bien discret nord à bavois la halle à
ses cuisines du truc quoi l'accord
d'open si je me couvre les dents comment
jours était levé
oh [ __ ] c'était une hélice
c'est bon ça en marche ça doit marcher
je me trompe non non ça la good
ça a l'air très très bien et bien qu
avons-nous d'autres un ballet allez on
fait une course sur le bas les mailles
potter au génie des abeilles s'est passé
quoi ici la fit pas [ __ ] donc ça c'est
l'homme voilà très bien donc on a fait
notre petit truc
est-ce que je peux pas passer quelque
part bon au moins on a rétabli la
machine se doit être l'électricité je
pense what a fortement fait c'est un
abattoir je pense seulement il avait
tracé transformé en lieu de décapitation
pour humains nous avons enquêté sur ces
jeunes entreprises qui fait excuser moi
j'aime bien part aux élections alors
rien n'a plus rien ici plus rien ici
waouh c'est quoi ça what y avait
quasimodo dans la maison il y avait
quasimodo dans ma [ __ ] de maison khin
des monos le nom de new day pas un truc
je suis sûr et un truc à faire
allégeance un billard au lait qui sait
qu'ils gèrent j'espère un petit verre
francs [ __ ] mais j'ai à me semblent
toujours voir des gens partout quoi
peut-être pouvoir repasser par là bas du
coup je suis en train de faire tous les
tableaux comme un vieux gars donc ça
c'est le téléphone de talent à ressasser
la porte par laquelle on ne peut pas
vraiment adapté que ça a changé
non c'est toujours restricted area ch et
naga alors peut-être par la spa la
grande salle où il s'est fait que les
catalans si c'est ça je suis sûr que là
est un truc à faire
obligé avec ces animaux est tous là il
ya un truc à faire [ __ ] à je n'ai pas
eu cette porte à bâle n'est pas d'une
grande utilité ma foi s'il vous plaît
les animaux mais je peux carrément
prendre les trucs et le à allah ok j'ai
peut-être trouver quelque chose
hu au [ __ ] c'est la première fois dans
un jeu que je m'en sors comme ça quoi
c'est incroyable alors of utah je suis
encore choqué ce que je veux découvrir
au lavage [ __ ] pro allez hop
c'est un petit armengol c
hmg au regard des chaises tout se remet
en place il me semble j'entends un mec
qui claquent des dents
mais comme il se fout de ma gueule
[ __ ] de chasse dégage non horiuchi
l'ennemi hors ue au mfg killing [ __ ]
[ __ ] est ici à sa cheval prendre non
ça non plus à madaya forcément vérifier
comment on trouve le chemin
simon un truc à faire [ __ ] ça me rend
dingue d'eva [ __ ] j'ai cru entendre
quelqu'un quelque chose dont je me suis
gouré
je suis surpris tâche pas fou bon eh
bien écoutez 1
on a plus qu'à trouver d'autres secrets
coucou toi enfin gouzi gouzi bon
arrêtons les bêtises
au maire demandait tout de même plus
parler
a attendu l'âge il y avait un bruit trop
bizarre [ __ ] mais au final je deviens
fou je deviens complètement fou
peut-être celle ci s'est débloquée au
lavage [ __ ] mais quel genre de
personne fait ça et ça n'a pas changé
ici le jeu boit pas
j'ai bon et bien voilà
oh [ __ ] il m'a fait tellement peur à
la fois que bon et bien voilà je regarde
l'heure quand même eh ben il est vain et
ben ça va faire 20 minutes de vidéo
j'aimerais bien trouver la suite quand
même je serai une bonne chose alors on
va c'est rue la suite la suite s'il vous
plaît écoutez ce bruit s'est répandu
qu'on a touché nos grands-mères d'1 les
pendules qu'il faut que la nuit tu ne
dors pas voilà à bien je fais trop caca
dessus
ah voilà on a trouvé un truc les mains
ce temps son je n'arrête pas de frotter
mais l'auteur ne s'en va pas fort quand
vais-je pouvoir toucher mes enfants etc
ses mains là et quand vais-je pouvoir
les embrasse avec d'élèves qui ont donné
de telles instructions que bonne
question je nomme ce tiroir cache
quelque chose
bouteilles de vin à mais j'arrive là
dedans il se met à parler là et
maintenant il fait plus rien allez on se
recouche allez y en a marre bon eh bien
écoutez je pense que c'était déjà pas
mal pour un premier épisode avait des
petites frayeurs on se retrouve dans
tous ces épisodes très bientôt tout le
monde puisse à bientôt
la planète
photo richard ray